"He could have added fortune and fame, but
caring for neither, he found happiness and
honor in being helpful to the world."
Those words are found on the gravestone of
George Washington Carver, an inspirational
scientist who was once dubbed by TIME Magazine
as the “Black Leonardo.”
This was apropos as Carver regarded himself
more of an artist who used natural things
rather than a true scientist.
“Cook-stove chemists” was how he jokingly
referred to himself and his research team.
At a time of high racial tensions, when he
was part of a community that was still heavily
marginalized and discriminated against, the
talent and achievements of George Carver transcended
all color barriers and were appreciated by
the entire nation.
And, despite all this, most simply remember
him as the “Peanut Man.”
His work with peanuts brought him the most
success, although even by Carver’s own admission,
it was not his greatest work.
But everything he did, he did with a purpose
- to help “the furthest man down.”
Today, we take a look at the full extent of
the career and legacy of George Washington
Carver.
Early Years & Education
George Washington Carver was born in a small
town called Diamond Grove in Newton County,
Missouri, today known simply as Diamond.
His birth date is a mystery.
Because he was born into slavery, the exact
date was never recorded.
It was sometime during the mid 1860s, but
before slavery was abolished in January 1865.
Later, Carver said that it happened “near
the end of the war” so 1864 is generally
given as his year of birth.
Right from the very beginning, Carver experienced
great tragedy and we’re talking about more
than the obvious misery of being born a slave.
His parents were Mary and Giles and they were
owned by a German-American immigrant named
Moses Carver.
His father died before he was born and when
George was just an infant, he, his mother,
and older sister were kidnapped by bushwackers
and taken to be sold in Arkansas.
Moses Carver hired a man to get them back,
but he was only able to track down and recover
George in exchange for a horse.
Afterwards, slavery may have been abolished,
but the boy was still an orphan.
Fortunately for him, Moses Carver and his
wife Susan took in George and his older brother
James and raised them as their own.
George was a frail child and was often sick
during his childhood.
Therefore, he was too weak to work on the
farm with Moses and James so, instead, he
helped Susan Carver around the home by doing
chores, cooking, and tending the garden.
During their free time, Susan taught him to
read and write.
He showed an intellectual aptitude from a
young age and his adoptive guardians encouraged
him to pursue an education.
Around the age of 12, George wanted to enroll
in school.
However, he couldn’t do that in Diamond
Grove because it only had one public school
and it did not accept black pupils.
Instead, he traveled to the county seat of
Neosho about ten miles away.
From this point on, he left the Carver farm,
more or less.
He would sometimes return and stay for a weekend
but, other than that, he kept moving from
one place to another to further his education.
It was also in Neosho that he first started
going by “George Carver” as, up until
that point, he kept referring to himself as
“Carver’s George.”
The “Washington” he added later in honor
of a man who played an important role in his
life.
Due to discrimination, Carver had to jump
from one school to the next before finding
acceptance.
He eventually managed to obtain a high school
diploma after graduating from Minneapolis
High School in Minneapolis, Kansas.
From there, George wanted to move on to college.
After being rejected by most of the institutions
he applied for, Carver was finally accepted
sight unseen by Highland College in Kansas,
but they, too, later rejected him once they
discovered that he was black.
Feeling a bit discouraged, George gave up
his dream of going to college for a while
and, instead, claimed a homestead which he
farmed alone, while simultaneously doing odd
jobs and working as a ranch hand to support
himself.
He did this for a few years but, by the late
1880s, Carver was ready to move on to something
else.
He managed to secure a loan from a bank and
he left Kansas, making his way to Iowa.
In the city of Winterset, he met and befriended
a white couple called the Milhollands who
urged him to continue his higher education.
Although reluctant at first, Carver eventually
relented and enrolled in a little Methodist
school in Indianola, Iowa, called Simpson
College.
The time he spent there had a deep effect
on George Carver, not just from a career perspective,
but also from a spiritual one.
It greatly strengthened his Christian faith
as he finally found a place which accepted
everyone regardless of race and made him “believe
[he] was a real human being.”
Carver studied a multitude of subjects at
Simpson College but, somewhat unexpectedly,
focused mainly on art, particularly painting.
This had been a passion of his ever since
he was a young man, but his teacher, Etta
Budd , did not think that a black man in that
day and age had a chance of making a decent
living as a painter.
When she found out that Carver was also interested
in plants, she encouraged him to switch to
botany and enroll at the Iowa State Agricultural
College in Ames where her father taught horticulture.
Going to Tuskegee
In 1891, George Carver became the first black
man accepted at Iowa State University.
Now fully living his dream, he embraced all
facets of campus life.
Carver was on the debate club, the athletics
team, he was captain of the campus military
regiment, he wrote poetry published in the
student newspaper and two of his paintings
were even exhibited at the Chicago World’s
Fair in 1893.
But, of course, it was his agricultural work
that earned him the most praise.
After presenting his thesis in 1894 titled
“Plants as Modified by Man,” Carver graduated
and continued to study for his master’s
degree.
His professors were so impressed with his
work that they asked him to begin teaching,
as well.
His master’s program saw Carver work as
assistant botanist for the College Experiment
Station, focusing on plant pathology (which
is the study of disease in plants) and mycology
(which is the study of fungi).
During this time, he wrote several papers
on his work that were published and started
garnering him a reputation as one of the country’s
leading young scientists.
He completed his master’s degree in 1896.
Now that his education was complete, Carver
was ready to embark on a permanent career
as teacher and researcher.
He wasn’t hurting for offers but, in the
end, he chose a young institution in Tuskegee,
Alabama, that had only been established 15
years prior.
It was the Tuskegee Institute, known today
as Tuskegee University, the passion project
of prominent civil rights activist Booker
T. Washington . Widely influential and respected
among the elite circles of American society,
Washington wanted to set up a university that
could provide a higher education for black
people without fear of discrimnation.
He founded the Tuskegee Institute in 1881
with the help of donations from industrialists
such as Andrew Carnegie and John D. Rockefeller.
Around the mid 1890s, Washington had entered
the second phase of his vision for his university
which was to recruit the most talented black
teachers and scientists in the country.
Obviously, Carver was on his list and he clearly
shared Washington’s vision.
In 1896, Carver moved to Alabama where he
accepted a position with the Agriculture Department
at the Tuskegee Institute, one he would keep
for the rest of his life.
You might expect that the pairing of Carver
and Washington to be a match made in heaven,
but the two actually butted heads quite often.
Those who knew them believed they had opposing
personalities.
Washington was a pragmatist who set a goal
and tried to accomplish it as fast as possible.
Carver, on the other hand, was more of a dreamer
who liked to fritter the time away in his
lab, either painting or looking after his
plants.
As the director of the newly created Agricultural
Experiment Station, George Carver expected
his job to mostly involve research which was
what he was interested in.
However, Washington also wanted him to manage
the farms, teach classes, and serve on several
committees and councils.
It was the bureaucracy and all the paperwork
that Carver loathed most of all.
He threatened to quit several times during
Washington’s tenure as President of the
Tuskegee Institute.
The latter always managed to smooth things
over, but he also flat-out refused to give
into some of Carver’s requests such as giving
up his teaching duties.
Despite their adversarial professional relationship,
the two had a healthy respect for each other
and always spoke highly of one another.
Carver would later even add “Washington”
to his name in honor of the civil rights leader.
Besides his spats with the university leadership,
Carver wasn’t exactly popular with the other
faculty members when he first came in, either.
Many of them resented the privileges that
Washington offered him in order to get him
to come to Tuskegee.
This was still in the infancy stages of the
university which did not have a lot of space
or money to go around.
Other faculty members had to live two in one
dormitory room if they were unmarried and
they made, on average, $400 a year.
Carver, on the other hand, had an annual salary
of $1,000 plus expenses and got two dormitory
rooms all to himself.
How to Improve Your Crops
Despite the various administrative obstacles
that Carver encountered during his time at
Tuskegee, they did not hamper his effectiveness
as a scientist or researcher.
He decided that his efforts would best be
spent helping the farmers of America, particularly
in the southern states because Carver believed
that they would suffer in the years and decades
that followed due to their over-reliance on
cotton.
The practice of growing the same crop in the
same place year after year after year is called
monocropping.
It is a problem because it depletes the soil
of the same nutrients over and over again
and leads to soil erosion which, in turn,
will result in much poorer crop yields in
the future.
Cotton, for example, is quite a demanding
crop that uses up a lot of nitrogen in order
to grow.
To alleviate the issue of monocropping, farmers
sometimes practiced crop rotation which simply
involved alternating between different crops
for subsequent growing seasons so that the
soil had time to build up its nutrients again.
George Carver was a big proponent of crop
rotation, but he did not invent it, just to
be clear.
It had been practiced since ancient times,
but farmers from the American South had no
interest in it because they regarded cotton
as the only cash crop around.
Anything else would not have been anywhere
near as useful and, therefore, would not have
made as much money.
At first, Carver presented other ideas, such
as suggesting that farmers use commercial
fertilizer with a high nitrogen content or
that they buy a second horse and use a two-horse
plow which would till the soil deeper.
These suggestions were seen as a bit tone-deaf,
coming from someone who didn’t truly grasp
the situation in the South.
It wasn’t that farmers were unaware of these
solutions, or that they were ignorant to the
problems caused by monocropping, but that
they did not have any money to do anything
about it.
The farmers that Carver aimed to help were
all poor, and many of them were black.
Following the abolition of slavery, wealthy
landowners gave them parcels of land which
they could work in exchange for a set fee
or a percentage of the crop.
Their profit margins were razor thin and even
just one bad growing season could cause them
to lose everything and plunge them into crippling
debt.
They had very few land rights and were up
against a system which was completely stacked
against them.
It was a “system of near slavery,” as
one historian described it.
Therefore, since the land was never truly
theirs, anyway, the farmers had almost no
incentive to care about the health of the
soil, let alone spend whatever money they
saved up in order to improve it.
Carver soon realized the extent of the issues
that plagued the poor southern farmers so
his research focused on other ways to improve
their work that did not necessarily require
any serious investments.
In this regard, almost all of the ideas he
had while working at Tuskegee were published
in the form of bulletins.
He issued 44 of these bulletins between 1898
and 1943.
The first one, for example, was titled “Feeding
Acorns” and it simply encouraged farmers
to use acorns to fatten up their livestock
as a cheaper alternative to corn that, otherwise,
typically went to waste.
Carver’s most popular bulletin was No. 31
from 1916 which saw multiple reprintings.
Titled “How to Grow the Peanut & 105 Ways
of Preparing It for Human Consumption,”
it was a list of recipes collected from other
cookbooks, magazines, newspapers, and agricultural
bulletins.
Carver’s educational efforts did not consist
solely of these bulletins.
He still felt that his information was not
reaching all of its intended audience, mainly
because a lot of the farmers were illiterate
or simply because they were not expecting
any kind of actual help from an official institution.
Carver decided that he needed a more direct
way to bring education to these people and,
thus, the Jesup Agricultural Wagon was born.
Founded in 1906 by George Carver, this was
the first step in the Movable School outreach
program of the Tuskegee Institute and was
named after New York banker Morris Ketchum
Jesup who funded the program.
These wagons would travel from farm to farm
with equipment and instructional charts and
give lectures to farmers on how to improve
the quality of their soil and alternate cotton
with other crops.
It proved successful enough that the United
States Department of Agriculture eventually
adopted it for their own outreach program.
The Peanut Man
In order to convince farmers to willingly
switch out their cotton with other crops,
Carver needed to show them that it was possible
for them to make a living by growing other
things.
Thus he embarked on a new mission which was
to research and develop new applications for
crops that he felt had been overlooked.
Of course, we all know about the most famous
one of all - the peanut.
In the minds of many, finding 300 uses for
the peanut is still Carver’s main claim
to fame.
One of the main reasons why the agricultural
scientist focused on this legume was because
the peanut was quite adept at repairing the
damage done to the soil by cotton.
Not only did it have meager nitrogen needs,
but it could also grow with relatively little
water consumption.
As we already mentioned, 105 of those 300
uses were food recipes which he presented
in his most popular bulletin.
They included: flour, chili sauce, dry coffee,
instant coffee, chop suey sauce, mayonnaise,
meat loaf, salad oil, buttermilk, mock chicken,
mock duck, mock goose, vinegar, caramel, cheese
pimento, peanut wafers, and many, many more.
Of course, that was just the tip of the peanutty
iceberg.
Carver also showed that the legume could be
used to make various types of feed for livestock,
plus a dozen different types of beverages.
He used it for medicines such as rubbing oils,
tonics, and laxatives; and numerous cosmetics
such as shampoo, hand & face lotions, shaving
cream, soap, pomade, and dandruff cures.
The peanut was useful around the house, as
well.
Carver turned it into laundry soap, leather
dyes, paints, wood stains, insecticide, various
types of paper, metal polish, diesel fuel
and gasoline, rubber, ink, linoleum, axle
grease, lubricating oil, and insulating board.
As you can see, the peanut was an all-purpose,
practical crop, but almost none of these ideas
actually took off.
Some of them had already been around for a
while.
After all, Carver made no pretense to have
come up with all of them, nor did he argue
that they were superior to their alternatives.
That was not the point.
Carver’s goal was to show southern farmers,
and the country as a whole, that it was possible
to develop other cash crops apart from cotton.
Given that Carver’s hundreds of uses for
peanuts never became very popular, it is a
little strange that the two are so inexorably
linked.
Historians point the finger at an obscure
event from Carver’s life when he gave an
impassioned testimony before Congress.
It was the moment that permanently connected
the scientist to the legume in the public
mind, but then the event itself was forgotten
so, nowadays, people remember the connection,
but not its origins.
Back in 1921, the U.S.
Government wanted to place a tariff on imported
peanuts.
Carver testified before the U.S. House Ways
and Means Committee and gave a dazzling speech
to support the tariff in order to bolster
the nation’s own growth of peanuts.
The tariff was passed and, afterwards, Carver
became somewhat of a media sensation.
One more thing that should be specified about
George Washington Carver’s nutty career
is that he did not invent peanut butter.
This might be a common belief, but it is incorrect
as peanut butter already existed by the time
he started publishing his bulletins.
In fact, the oldest references to the salty
snack go all the way back to the Aztecs and
the Incas who made a paste out of ground up
roasted peanuts.
The first to make modern peanut butter was
Canadian chemist Marcellus Gilmore Edson who
patented peanut-candy, as he called it, in
1884.
The process was later refined by John Harvey
Kellogg of Kellogg’s cereal fame and, in
1903, Dr. Ambrose Straub invented a machine
especially designed to make peanut butter.
Legacy & Last Years
According to Carver himself, his research
into peanuts was not the greatest work of
his career.
Even so, he never actively discouraged anyone
from making the association between the two
which is why he is still so closely associated
with the legume even today.
He didn’t mind the fame that he enjoyed
in the last decades of his life after his
testimony before Congress.
He believed that he could use it to advance
his causes, to promote the Tuskegee Institute
and to encourage more racial integration.
Carver’s research into sustainable farming
ended up saving countless farmers from ruin
when the boll weevil ravaged the southern
cotton crops at the start of the 20th century.
This ravenous pest made its way from Mexico
around 1892 and, in just a couple of decades,
turned into a major threat not only to all
the cotton crops in the country, but the economy
which was completely reliant on them.
This “wave of evil,” as it was dubbed
by the USDA, did not succeed in destroying
the financial state of the South thanks to
George Carver and others like him who advocated
for crop diversification.
Peanut plantation expanded from 500,000 acres
in 1916 to over four million acres in 1918
and continued growing from there.
The city of Enterprise, Alabama, even has
a monument dedicated to the boll weevil, the
first such structure in the world made to
honor an agricultural pest.
They dubbed the insect a “herald of prosperity”
and were grateful that it forced the locals
to switch to growing peanuts instead of cotton
which triggered a period of affluence for
the city.
And it wasn’t just peanuts.
Although the legume was Carver’s bread and
(peanut) butter, if you will, he saw the problem
in trying to prevent monocropping by simply
switching one crop with another crop.
Therefore, he also advocated for the cultivation
of other plants such as soybeans and pecans.
He was a big supporter of the sweet potato,
almost as big as the peanut.
He saw many similarities between them in terms
of the benefits they would provide to cotton
farmers and how easy they were to grow.
While Carver wasn’t as imaginative with
the sweet potato, he still found over a hundred
uses for the root vegetable.
They included flour, sugar, starch, vinegar,
over a dozen varieties of candy, yeast, dry
& instant coffee, sauce, hog feed, alcohol,
ink, paper, dyes, paints, and synthetic silk.
Some argue that George Carver’s true legacy
was that of a pioneering environmentalist.
There is no doubting that the ideas he promoted
about sustainability and self-sufficiency
had an impact on the world around him, perhaps
more significant, if not more well-known,
than his work with peanuts.
In his later years, Carver served as agricultural
advisor to three U.S. Presidents.
He counselled Gandhi on matters of nutrition
and agriculture.
He taught Henry Ford how to make peanut rubber
during World War II.
It might be a little hard to pinpoint exactly
what George Washington Carver should be remembered
for, but when he talked, people listened.
He died on January 5, 1943, approximately
79 years old.
Afterwards, there was talk of establishing
a national monument in his honor but, due
to World War II, all such non-essential expenditures
were banned by presidential order.
However, a senator from his home state of
Missouri sponsored a bill to make an exception
in order “to do honor to one of the truly
great Americans.”
That senator was future President Harry S.
Truman and his bill was passed in both houses
unanimously.